today's topic Amanda steals if you
haven't heard the news Amanda Steel's
has decided to leave the real she's
decided not to renew her contract we
have a contentious history with Amanda
we've covered some of her were stakes
were pretty uh very keen on calling
around when she says dumb but let's find
out why she left the real and why I
think this is important for you guys to
listen in on all right I did not renew
it because it doesn't feel good to my
soul to be at a place where I cannot
speak to my people the way they need to
be spoken to and where the people who
are speaking to me in disparaging ways
are not being handled I I have gratitude
every morning I wake up with gratitude
every morning that I found myself to
I've created a life for myself where I
don't have to do things just for money
where I can be like y'all can keep that
out of here but I think a lot of that
has also come from like my own
confidence that like I'll find the brain
you know you know in a manner that
serves me I got a lot of messages people
kind of expecting us to take like a
victory lap you know people expecting us
to kind of just laugh her on the way out
and the truth is what I feel about hers
are relevant to whether or not I think
this is a good thing Amanda seals for
all her faults says what she thinks and
what she feels no matter how dumb I
think it is I want her to be able to
express herself unapologetically the
same way I want every other voice to be
able to express themselves
unapologetically without filters yet it
and then in the court of public opinion
we can criticize and these ideas and
debate them and that's what healthy
debate is for unfortunately when you
become part of a television show
everything does become edited it goes
through all these filters we don't know
a hundred percent if that's who you are
or if you're projecting your ideas
accurately and so we criticize you for
not knowing that it doesn't mean that
you shouldn't be criticized for them
because at the end of day you signed up
to be on that platform you signed up for
them to have control over this and so
you do suffer the consequences
but I prefer when people have their own
platforms or people can speak on
platforms where they're uninhibited so
that if I am criticizing them I know
what's going on and I know it's not
manipulated edited if I [ __ ] up I
[ __ ] up
you know so that's why I'm happy I
didn't the demos gonna be happy when
artists have the autonomy and the
swaying power to be able to make those
choices for themselves this is in no way
an endorsement of Amanda's character
it's no way an endorsement of what she
says all the time but it is an
endorsement of the idea that individuals
are powerful our voices are what
perpetuates it pushes these television
shows forward we don't need the networks
the networks need us and anytime we can
empower individual voices and
authenticity I will empower even if its
authenticity I don't like I don't give a
[ __ ] I want you to be able to say what
you think undisturbed so good for Amanda
I am glad that she's able to have this
way have her way with regards to this
and when it comes to the real y'all got
to start changing your name cuz alright
because for all the faults that Amanda
said she was real sometimes real dumb
but still real and the idea that you got
her off the show because she was making
some people upset and she was butting
heads
well yeah you guys said you wanted women
of color who can discuss things and
really have their talks between each
other with like contrasting opinions but
I'll get rid of one girl or push her out
or create an environment that's not
conducive to that very ethos so I
criticize the show it's a bad look for
them
I just can't function in this place the
same way yeah cuz I know a lot of us do
just for bread yeah and there is a
luxury in not having to do just for
bread that is a she's uh she's
definitely right about that part
I have no disagreement what she just
said about not having to need bread not
having to do stuff you don't want to do
I say no load no talk even when I didn't
have money or didn't have a lot of it I
said no to LA she because I'm not in a
rush to make money but I do know people
who will do [ __ ] that will compromise
their values severely just for money and
people will look at you strained yeah
people will look at you funny if you if
you like I don't want to do that people
told me yeah but that's the game preach
yeah that's the game that's so many
times you have to do that I'm like yeah
but I don't want to do that that's corny
I'm not gonna participate in that show
yo but you gotta do a lot as much as you
want as much as you can because that's
the game I'm like yeah
No who says that's the game and who made
these rules and who acts like these
rules are always the same because I can
assure you the way we did it was in part
of the game but now we get to make and
call our own shots when it comes to the
table we we didn't even come through the
back door we we kick we were late man
yeah we came in right through the wall
we thought that she [ __ ] and we put a
door that door didn't even exist before
we go off cuz I know we bought two we
bought the go only to give him contact
so we're comedians right and when we
were coming up and we were doing
stand-up comedy and we were at the open
mikes every time there would be a lot of
veteran comics would see the YouTube
videos back what are you guys doing
that's a waste of time it's stupid it's
unfunny blah blah blah go fast forward
four years later you know we've done the
largest Comedy Festival in the world
we've gone the big stage we are now
planning an international tour because
the fact that we invested in different
avenues and we didn't follow the game I
wasn't necessarily gonna suck up to
people in order to get to certain spots
I wasn't going to
buddy-buddy up with people that I
thought were morally reprehensible just
so it could further my career and I
think that let me sleep well at night
but also pushed me to create my own
Avenue in order which I can grow from
that you see what I'm saying and so now
today I'm watching these very same
comedians struggling and still hard time
work and I'm like the game isn't what
you thought it was but there you were
playing with one leg and I was like no
I've got two legs I'm gonna utilize the
both of them so I don't like this idea
that people say I'm gonna compromise my
values because that's the rule that
games no you're compromising your values
because you don't want to trail blazing
a path for yourself and I don't want to
sound like arrogant saying I trail
blazed like it's not that thing to do
with that but I do think there is
something honorable about not not
compromising your values and finding a
different way to get [ __ ] done rather
than just saying it's the only way
that's all
oh here roll the dices be exactly with
three boys I mean I play with three
dices okay so they gave you two I got
one they gave me one now you gotta play
with that one dice I'm like I got two
more dice if you hey i'ma roll all the
dice if I need a six to win leave it
it's gonna be hard not to get it look at
that
you wait you say you tell me you didn't
just get an opening spot at the festival
you got the whole show exactly what no
you have to get that so you have to
learn I'm not playing that rule I'm not
playing that game I'm honest yeah yeah
at the real one of my producers that
they were my showrunner at the real we
were we were talking when we were doing
a mod aubrey like she was like but um
his name um Adrian say his name and Asia
was like oh my god brie and she was like
right yeah I just can't pronounce his
name and I'm like you can't pronounce a
mod I'm not in a space where I can as a
full black woman have my voice and my
co-workers also have their voices and
where the people at the top are not
respecting the necessity for black
voices to be at the top - she's genuine
about it I understand where she's coming
from
I understand all that I thought that
coming signed up to the show when she
signed up to the soil was like boo boo
honey chickens are a job you know damn
well you don't fit in there I'm not a
family I'm not a fan of what's-her-name
I can't say her name I'm just kidding
okay his name you need to learn you need
to learn now yeah I'm not yeah you like
kissing a roast and you can say my name
I'm not a fan of Amanda seals I'm not
but it's not because I'm not a fan of
someone that everything that person
doesn't say is bad now that being said
the minute it was announced that she was
part of that show I was like that she's
not gonna last
hmm that's just not gonna last because
she's too much out there yeah you know
if it's social it's very me II it's
always this sort of way it is it is what
it is I'm not again without offending
the soap but yeah I understand what
you're coming from I understand like you
get into situations sometimes where I'm
not talking about the business business
you get into situation where you have to
sign
shocking stuff like that and you you are
your own person but the way this [ __ ]
work and the way it is set up the way
this thing work it is not made to make
you look in your best interests and it's
time what I'm saying it's not made for
you it's like you're still yourself but
you don't know anything you're not the
one that does none of that the editing
how you project yourself how you look
and stuff like that so unfortunately me
doing being me being part of the hammer
and preach think I've unfortunately
become became a fan of be able to edit
your own [ __ ] because when you edit your
own things you have control a hundred
percent of the control of what you do
and what you put out this
[Music]
you took all your mom's clothes no no
this one I got from actual throw shot
I rip the collar off yeah yeah yeah I
had to moved I don't like like really
like a long hate it was a long ass [ __ ]
yeah yeah some of them are too much this
is 70 [ __ ] then no no I see it I see the
fabric anyways yes let's get to it
and I'm like you can't pronounce a mod
are we I heard that [ __ ] so many times
well over just because your name is not
flowers I'm Michelle or Emmanuel or ie
or Matt yeah you know we think that are
really common in here in French right
you feel like they don't make an effort
some I've heard know my dad I've heard
that I can't pronounce his name and the
name is not that complicated
I've heard that here I've heard that in
this stage everything like yo I don't
know I can't around his name yo it's my
my - my my do is like two times MA and
do with you're actually French words
like you can pronounce I I just get I
heard that before
I I heard that I heard people see that
and pretty high place people in
corporations and jobs that I had and
they just like yeah yes yeah people
don't make an effort if they don't sound
like what you used to be can't pronounce
it heard that what do you think about
that it's done it's done it's like cuz I
noticed there are some languages because
I'm a fan of languages right there are
some languages and some accent that
you're gonna say that are it's gonna be
really like it's in tricky right like
there's some there's some languages in
Asia right we're just the Anto nation
means something else
I don't know if it's Thailand well I
don't know if it but if you say cow cow
cow cow
I said nine eggs cow and I said another
[ __ ] well it's technically the same word
right same one but because you're an
Tunisian is gonna be different I'm gonna
say our whole other
so when you thought and you don't have
the proper intonation is the difference
between a compliment and a fight okay
okay so I understand these countries
sometimes even like example Arabic
languages with sometimes with the it can
be intricate cuz sometimes you're not
gonna pronounce the words properly and
you're not they're not they're just not
gonna understand what you're saying
because it's literally something
something else hmm you know so yeah I
remember like I think like I it's funny
because I didn't know how to said girls
I was talking with another one of my
friends and she's from Egypt right you
know talking to her and I say yo this
girl really looks good she's got me
because I've gotta go really looks good
it's like what's her name something I
think her name is fresh fereshta and I
didn't pronounce it properly and she's
like what's her name
and I repeat I repeated it like fereshta
or fresh I don't know how I said it but
it's not finished
that's what I said and she's like that
means tablecloth that was her name I was
a beautiful name right but for the other
one it was just something else you
understand what I'm saying
so depending on what you say and I
understand those languages but there's
the other [ __ ] that you're a mod
Barberie it's not hard okay make an
effort and I've heard that discourse I
heard and I'm like you can't pronounce a
mod first of all the word armory is
actually in it may not be spelled the
same but it is pronounced name it's a
study of trees it's literally like in
the English language so it's not even
like it's like I'm like you know what
you know it's not an English language
your last name that has seven consonants
lined up against each other and yet we
are able to pronounce that so I am we
gift we gift you know we got but the
like you need to learn this now I'm
Marberry
and she was like a mod I'm like figure
it out but the reason I bring that up is
because it is so easy
that is pretty extra you need to learn
this now I get it
I'm with you that it's kind of stupid
that she can't say the name but that's a
little bit over the top are we in
agreement yeah absolutely but then again
you know man the seals yeah she's not
doing anything she's not doing anything
outside of what I would accept expect
her to do yeah so when people say she's
difficult to work with I can understand
yeah and if I sympathize with her
position I'm like yeah you're not
helping yourself but anyways